you
[Music]
okay why don't we get started can you
hear me okay great
hi I'm Bill Dolan I'm the manager of the
MS our natural language processing group
and welcome to this session on
conversational systems in the era of
deep learning and big data just going to
talk very quickly because we have a
pretty full set of talks today with
pretty tight scheduling but we have a
number of great speakers the list is
there Alan Ritter from Ohio State
Michelle Kelly in this event Wendy and
Jason Williams from here and Emmas our
Jackie Chun from McGill and Ian Layne
from CMU all will be giving their
perspective on what's been happening in
the area of dialogue where in the last
several years the availability of
massive data around dialogues
conversations with people are having
with each other on social media for
example along with better algorithms
neural algorithms in particular have
really upended the field of dialogue and
open up new possibilities in areas that
had been pretty static for most of my
career and natural language processing
it feels suddenly like things are moving
very fast and moving toward a really
useful future pretty soon so without any
further ado I'm just going to hand
things over to Alan who is going to give
the first talk and word the level what
he's done it I think I can just do that
okay can everyone hear me okay great
okay
thanks Bill so yes I just sort of
following up just straight from from
what Bill was talking about I'd like to
sort of you know sort of step back a
little bit and sort of give this kind of
like flashback to like 2010 or so you
know so at this time I think it's sort
of fair to say that dialogue systems are
mostly based on handwritten rules
there's some exceptions like you know
these goal-directed data dialogue
systems have sort of you know components
that are based on machine learning but
at a high level you know conversational
agents are really sort of rule-based
systems at this time right so around the
same time you know we were seeing a lot
of progress in statistical machine
translation so machine translation
algorithms were becoming really
successful by taking advantage of the
huge amounts of bilingual text that was
available on the web and applying
statistical methods to learn how to
translate between languages right so
right so you know I was kind of just
happened to be in the right place at the
right time working with Bill Dolan and
Colin sherry and so we were sort of
thinking well you know these days
there's huge amounts of conversational
data that's you know easily available to
get access to online so if we just look
at Twitter alone there's people are
having over 500 million conversations
every month this is sort of like an
order of magnitude larger than available
you know parallel corpora that people
are using for learning translation
models so you know it's kind of a
natural question of like okay can we
apply some of these data driven methods
borrowed from statistical machine
translation and apply them to learning
conversational agents just directly from
data okay so just a quick sort of side
note I'm also doing a lot of work on
sort of extracting knowledge from big
noisy text corpora as well but I'll sort
of focus mostly on dialogue here I'll
bring this up again at the end maybe
so anyways we kind of made this marriage
between dialogue and MT and there's been
a lot of work along these lines
since then okay so um you know it turns
out this wasn't totally trivial to get
working so you know if you think about
like dialogue it's actually very
different from translation so in
translation right the source and target
that we're trying to generate or
semantically equivalent to each other so
it's a much more constrained space
whereas in conversation you can reply
with almost anything to any input so you
know just to sort of illustrate that the
you know one of the first problems we
ran into is when we try to look at word
alignment on these big conversational
datasets they totally break down because
we have like these you know big chunks
of you know phrases that we can't sort
of decompose into any more fine-grained
word alignments and so you know we were
able to get around this by taking
advantage of these huge amount of data
and using some tricks and things like
that so you know once we're able to you
know do that and get some sort of large
phrase tables extracted from this data
then we can sort of translate messages
into responses using a process that
looks something like this where we have
an input sentence and you know the first
thing we're going to do is segment it
into phrases and then each phrase in the
input is going to get translated into a
phrase in the response so for example
here you know dinner might get
translated as YUM you know who wants to
might translate as want to come over
translates as be there and and you know
tomorrow is translating it tomorrow and
so each of these phrase pairs are being
mined from these really big
conversational corpora and then you know
we're just picking you know pairs that
have like sort of like a high
translation score and also have you know
generating a response that has like a
high score according to a language model
so this is the sort of noisy channel
model for for translation um okay so so
this you know worked and there was you
know people were sort of I think it was
you know pretty interesting but around
twenty fourteen or so there was
something interesting that happened that
neural networks basically
we took over in machine translation and
sort of soon after that people started
applying these neural network models for
dialogue as well you know basically
applying the same ideas and so here I'm
just showing a sample of some of the
work on this but there is kind of like a
key problem that like many of the neural
network translation models have that
were reported independently by multiple
different research groups which is that
they tend to generate really boring and
safe responses so they're not adding any
sort of new content to the conversation
and I think this actually makes a lot of
sense if you think about what they're
doing so these neural translation models
are trying to basically just generate a
response that has the highest possible
probability conditioned on some
conversational context but this isn't
necessarily like the best way to have a
conversation right is to say like the
most you know expected the most probable
thing in response to it to an input so
you know this you know there's these
some replies that are just sort of like
a good reply in almost any context so
almost anything you say to me I can say
I don't know and response but that's not
necessarily like a good conversation
right okay so um this led us to think
about you know okay so how can we design
different objective functions rather
than just trying to maximize the the
likelihood and so we're sort of thinking
about like okay how can we design models
that maximize some measure of expected
reward over the entire sort of feature
of the conversation and you know that
sort of sort of naturally leads to this
idea of reinforcement learning okay so I
just want to credit on a g-way we who's
a PhD student at Stanford who's really
the person that's been like driving this
this work forward okay so on okay so
just to kind of illustrate this let's
say we have two conversational agents
talking to each other so we might give
to one of these neural conversation
models an input that looks something
like this like how old are you and the
model replies I'm 16 so this looks okay
right and then the response to that is
going to be 16 question mark
and so at this point the model kind of
breaks down and says I don't know what
you're talking about and then the
response to that is you don't know what
you're saying and now we're stuck in
this like infinite loop right okay so so
what went wrong here so if we look back
you know maybe we can say this answer
although it's informative is not really
a good action to take because it sort of
doesn't leave any place for the
conversation to go like it's not adding
any new content but we don't really find
out that this is a bad action until
several steps later in the conversation
right so this sort of naturally looks
like a reinforcement learning problem
like we want to pick you know actions
that lead to you know good sequences of
conversation okay so just to sort of
formalize this a little bit so you know
how do we sort of formalize this problem
is a you know a Markov decision process
we can you know solve using
reinforcement learning so the states the
state space is basically you know we're
going to have a you know recurrent
neural network encoder that's going to
read in the input sentence and represent
it as a six sides vector representation
and then conditioned on that we're going
to take an action which is just going to
be a sentence that's generated by a
recurrent neural network language model
rate so of course there's been a lot of
previous work on reinforcement learning
for dialogue really the difference here
is we have you know an infinite action
space you can you know respond with any
sentence and the state spaces is also
infinite okay so to train these models
we basically just do this sort of
simulation process where we take a
message from our training set and have
the the model just talk to itself to
generate a conversation and we just sort
of repeatedly sample conversations from
the data and so basically you know given
one of these automatically generated
conversations we're then going to design
some reward functions that we can
automatically compute right and so
without going you know too much into the
details of the reward function basically
the the objective function we want to
maximize
some eyes is is just the expected reward
over the whole conversation and then
we're just going to use these policy
gradient methods to tune the parameters
of the encoder/decoder
response generation model to learn a
policy that maximizes expected reward
rate
and so these policy gradient methods
kind of make more sense than like
q-learning for example in our case
because we can initialize the policy
with the maximum likelihood parameters
all right so I kind of like waved my
hands a bit about how we define the
reward signal you know we came up
initially with some sort of heuristics
about how to do this but you know sort
of another idea is you know maybe we can
design a reward that's based on the idea
of the Turing test which is that you
know basically if we have you know a
person that's talking to you know a
computer or like another person if we
can sort of generate a chatbot that can
sort of talk to this person and fool
them into thinking that they're you know
talking to a person then you know that's
that should be like what we want to do
right and so this sort of naturally
leads to this idea of adversarial
learning which first came up in a
computer vision and so I'll just sort of
go over how that works in the context of
dialogue okay so basically what we're
going to do is to have a bunch of
real-world conversations so that we're
going to you know just sample
conversations from this data set and
then automatically generate responses to
the users input and separately we're
going to have this discriminator model
that's basically just going to try to
predict
is this a real conversation or a real
response or a response that was
generated by our model okay and so then
you know if the discriminator is fooled
we can sort of treat that as like a
reward signal so the model is basically
being trained to try and fool the
discriminator and we just sort of
alternate between training the the you
know or generative response model and
the discriminator and you know try to
generate you know better responses that
are
look more like human responses right and
so again we're just going to train this
using this these policy gradient methods
okay and so this actually leads to this
adversarial learning actually leads to
better responses so we you know compared
it against the the sort of heuristics
that I sort of skipped over by basically
just showing you know generating
conversations and then showing
evaluators on Mechanical Turk you know
conversations that are generated using
by the both the models and the
adversarial model wins most of the time
okay so just to kind of wrap up a little
bit so just thinking a little bit about
some future directions so another sort
of topic that I'm you know really
interested in is the sort of problem of
knowledge-based population and how can
we sort of you know build information
extraction systems that can sort of read
in all the the real-time text people are
writing on social media and in the news
every day and sort of maintain these
knowledge bases that are kind of you
know can you know constantly updated
with like the current state of the world
I think there's some really interesting
questions about how do we integrate you
know knowledge into these conversational
agents so that there can have sort of
like you know more meaningful you know
conversations based on uh you know
information that's contained in
knowledge bases so I think this is one
you know really really kind of promising
direction for for future work okay and
so just to wrap up a couple takeaways so
I talked about this data-driven approach
to dialogue where we're trying to have
you know open domain conversations on on
any topics learn from you know large
amounts of conversational data that are
sort of freely available on the web that
tends to lead to relatively boring sort
of content less conversations just by
itself so I talked about like one
possible way to address this which is
you know learning from delayed reward
and trying to have conversations that
maximize some measure of expected reward
over the sort of entire you know future
of the conversation and then finally I
you know briefly mentioned this approach
to add
Syrio learning sort of based on the
ideas the Turing test Thanks
[Applause]
well no questions I wonder if you might
comment a little bit more on the
difference that I remember being struck
by between the older statistical machine
translation models where the mappings
that were emerging from the parallel
they they were actually very content
full and very interesting and then as we
moved away from those models to neural
in the office it became clear suddenly
the responses were very fluent and they
were very very boring and it's
interesting I don't know if you have
thoughts on how to begin to pull those
two together yeah that's actually a good
point so yeah I think this issue of the
really boring responses and always
saying I don't know didn't come out as
much in a sort of traditional vicious
school phrase based translation methods
I also I feel like at the same time they
often generate they didn't sort of like
the neural models tend to be like sort
of more often generate something that
seems like reasonable like plausible in
the context so I feel like maybe they're
somehow you know maybe the statistical
empty models you can think of it's sort
of not totally optimizing the objectives
as well it's like you know maybe one way
to think about it so they're sort of you
know they're sort of injecting a little
bit more sort of randomness into how
they respond which feels more human in
some sense yeah very very fluent but not
interesting contributions of the neural
model momentum eh yeah I mean I think
one thing that's really promising about
the neural models is because they're
sort of end-to-end trainable you could
think about like in court incorporating
all kinds of additional context into the
conversation so in that way I think
there may be seem like a more promising
direction for for going in the future
you know other questions do you want to
set up oh sorry
is there constant
yeah it's good is there a concept of a
like personal identity facts about an
actual persona that goes into the
compensation system yeah I think there's
been some work along those lines
not that I've done personally but I
think also at MSR by also you guys were
collaborating with g'way I think on the
right right so yeah maybe you'll hear
about that in just a second okay thank
you cool
and next up splitting the slot or
Michelle galley and Lucia underwent
again
can you hear me yes okay good afternoon
everyone my name is Michelle Kelly and
today I'm going to be talking about work
we did recently at MSR on neuro
conversation model and more particularly
how to to tie them to the real world so
that's what we mean by ground the neural
conversation models and Lucy one day one
day was going to give the second half of
his talk so and before I get started I
want to acknowledge the many great
interns who had over the years and a
picture on the top we have we have many
we had interns back working on
conversational intelligence going back
to 2010 actually Allen and then anywhere
people came and at the bottom I just
well while this is me and Lucy giving a
talk this actually work of an entire
team of researchers most of most of
which people are in the MS are a INFP
group ok so what's the goal here and
Becca relates to what Alan was studying
in his previous talk is a what our goal
here is to learn to converse from lots
big amounts of training data and we want
so summer goals are we want the
conversation to be seamless and natural
to be totally open domain to be too
sober to be able to talk about many
different topics for example in this
example talking about the weather and
then switching on to maybe giving some
some travel recommendation and also be
of different URLs going from chit chat
and hopefully and that's actually one of
the main point of this talk is to move
to some a bit towards dialogues but are
not just about chit chat but maybe more
informational or maybe slightly more
task oriented okay and as Alan pointed
out there have been a lot of work in
that space
starting from 2011 and then first using
machine translation approaches when
moving on with neural approaches and
and a salon was pointing out there are
many challenges with this approach
things but I make kind of the
differences between a translation and
conversation models and things like the
blandness issue and and so on and about
many different issues I mean the hip of
the model for example that makes the
models pretty hard to train because
often times while in machine translation
you want to you have a simple mapping
with the source and target in
conversation you often want to enrich B
input with a lot of conversation textual
information know whatever was said
before in the conversation and
incorporate more information into that
so anyway we've we've been able to Train
pretty big conversation models up to 140
million conversations and and that's
often that's maybe one of the downside
of these models you need a lot of data
to kind of avoid this planet issue and
and even we've at amount of data you
still have issue which you can deal with
things like reinforcement learning but
now I would like to I mean what's the
point of a stock I want to see kind of a
different perspective here between this
line of work with a commercial model and
works but I've done in dialogue earlier
on so of course dialogue system in Iran
for a very long time and the more kind
of traditional way of building a
dialogue system is one where you have
more of an explicit undefined component
more explicit generation component and
there's also a burden able to tie with
the environment so that if you have some
kind of more structural representation
of the input or output band then that
enables to query for example a database
on knowing what's going on worse with
the neural model that but Allen and I
are talking about it's kind of moving
away from these where we don't have
these different boxes it's less of a
pipeline you have one integrated model
but canvas can be learned really end to
end with one big box but what we losing
in the process is that while you can
easily ground the standard more
traditional way of building that
system here we kind of lose for
grounding so I had two disadvantages
with this kind of lack of grounding I
mean the first one is of course you
don't have this tie of you know if I
cannot query like let's say you calendar
and things so on but if you ever
downside is like models like what we
train the neural models tend to be
uploaded pretty quickly so if you ask
you a question who's the president of
France and if you train this model let's
say three months ago then you might not
get the correct answer so it's kind of
the smaller we have to Train and then
just they get updated pretty fast so so
our goal recently in a group has been to
kind of exploit and get to try to get
the best of both worlds and do data
driven conversation very more grounded
way and the first step of doing that is
one where let's say you have you start
with a pipeline but it's a bit like a
restaurant sequence the sequence model
so you want to model the fact that you
go from an input but it's going to
kusakabe tonight which happened to be a
some Japanese restaurant and then it's a
kind of scenario where you want some
kind of grounding you want to have some
tie to an external knowledge base that
tells you maybe what who's a kabhi is so
the way to approach this problem is
we're actually not going to hand code
anything here we we want to explore two
source of knowledge one but is
conversational you are the input so at
the top you have conversation history
but kind of condition but actually
represent your dialogue history but also
you're going to infuse some facts that
are relevant to the context so for
example here in this kind of experiment
we've been running we we use Foursquare
data where any kind of fad for the
relevant of conversation added to the
context of a conversation and so the
motivation here is also that I mean
beyond enabling is grounding it's also a
natural way of infusing noncommercial
knowledge into the system so most of the
external knowledge would have is
actually not encoded I mean it's not
represented directly in the training
that a lot of it is
is is for external some things you might
find for example Inkigayo Foursquare so
the idea here is is that there are a lot
of patterns in like say Twitter reddit
where you see this pattern like you know
any good a restaurant in B and so on but
it's not instantiated we're particle
instantly we care about so we have this
external source like could be in our
case it was Foursquare it could be like
Wikipedia and in a way you're learning
the structure of the conversation
patterns from the Twitter data while you
can almost in a way like do some kind of
implicit slab filling through a non
conversational data and so here's an
example of ours
our system but is knowledge grounded so
I mean you can see some what's
interesting is like it enables this
landing of these two sorts of
information so the input is I'm going to
LAX and the response is nice Airport
terminal have a safe slide so how does a
flat it's more like representative of
what you might learn from Twitter
because you have this excuse a response
pattern like going to Airport have a
safe flight but also it says something
more specific about what terminal and
it's also sometimes I mean analyzing
what sometimes things go wrong here so
one of the response is the best fake
crew in the world five eliminated so
sometimes it does this blending the
perhaps not it's very good way and
sometimes mixing different reviews from
different people so I think it's now
it's able to do this blending of
different source of information provided
both grounded and grounded but with more
work to be done in terms of finding
perhaps some kind of contradiction so
anyway so this work is work on the
driven compressor and fully data-driven
conversation and we try to move to
something but it's more useful so if you
could see this on some kind of continuum
be doing doing something but pure
chitchat but cocktails is much earlier
work in this neural conversation model
and on the other hand doing something
but is more such completion so on one
end of the spy
you have more like traditional I mean
popular dialogue system but are grounded
and the other end of the spectrum you
have free data-driven ones but are
actually not grounded so this work is
actually one step toward doing something
but is still fully data-driven but
towards doing something a bit more
useful than just chitchat okay so and
Bevin other work on branded and branding
and fully data-driven models had been
exploring at MSR so I mean we've been
doing a lot of work on personalization
so if can you infuse knowledge about a
particular user into a conversation
maybe things that have been said to that
person or or by that person and we've
been also doing work on exploiting other
things like GPS and visual signal and
this is where my handing this over to
Lucy has been doing work in that space
I'm on but they haven't literally yeah
okay so just to pop back up so what
Michelle and Alan have just been
presenting to you or stated driven
conversation so if you you know input is
my son is a head and boy is he surprised
and then you know kind of the model
might say should be proud of himself
it's a fairly reflexive reaction now in
parallel I have been working on a
different type of grounding which you
may have seen me present last year at
the faculty summit where given an image
the task that we had formulated was to
generate a natural sounding question
that a person would like to answer so
this is these were not questions meant
to be answered by the by a computer
vision system these were interesting and
in gate meant to be interesting and
engaging questions that a person would
like to answer and we presented that
work in 2016
again it says slightly over
Epping set of authors and master and
mustapha's added from University of
Rochester and ischium misra from CMU
were the lead authors on that so it
makes sense to try to put these two
together so that's what we are now
calling image grounded conversation so
given a textual tweet if you were plus
an image that's included in the tweet
think of that together what would you
ask it when you receive that image and
text and what might you respond and this
is work that we've described in the
image grounded conversations a paper
that is currently up on archive and it's
being submitted to a major conference
the and I just want to point out this is
a very common thing so Mary Merritt Mary
Morris Ringel in 2015 estimates that
about twenty twenty seven percent of all
tweets are accompanied by some type of
image and that was rapidly increasing so
there are a lot of tweets that are you
know kind of include images so it's a
very natural task and so in fact that
leads us to one of the datasets that we
collected so from Twitter we collected
in this case just sampled a set of
250,000 conversations that are photo and
tweet followed by a question followed by
a response and that's our data set and
because that's the type of conversation
that we want to learn how to produce at
the same time we also generated a crowd
as a data set using the crowd for the
following reasons one is from our
question generation data set we had
eventful images so we presented a
selection of these images and asked the
first crowd worker to select an image
and make a comment about it as one would
do here so the question here was I
checked out the protest yesterday
we then brought in a second person into
the conversation who was constrained to
ask a question about this tweet + image
and they said do you think America can
overcome its racial divide and then we
put it back to the first person to
respond etc doing creating this crowd
dataset gives us the ability to source
five additional questions because this
one question is not the only possible
question that could have been asked and
to source multiple responses as well
again because given the background and
given the background and the the
background you could have multiple
responses so we further collected
multiple turns so that we in the future
can study longer conversations now the
key characteristics of this dataset are
that these are natural sounding
conversations about a shared image
they're grounded in the image the
conversation topics are about events and
actions that are evoked by the objects
in the image they're not about the image
themselves they're about what is
depicted by the image I did an analysis
to confirm that both the image and the
textual context are informative for the
question generation I did that by doing
a frame net analysis of this dialogue
confirming that as here this example the
question where is that from is related
in this case to the frame that is evoked
by the textual context look at what food
I ordered another possible question
could have been are there nuts in that
that would have been evoked by the food
framework from the image directly so we
see a good mix of some questions are
evoked by the image frame and some are
evoked by the textual frame so that
gives us a confidence that this is a
good data set where both vision and
texts are important
the following conversation of the other
characteristic that I'm particularly
looking for is that there is a complex
temporal and causal relations that are
observed across multiple turns in the
conversation just as you would expect so
I see a lot of different types of
relations that hold across multiple
turns so these are not simply
question-answer pairs that are linked
together it is a continued and a
consistent conversation and a change of
topics across the conversation so that
are is I think the dialogue that we
really aspire to and I'll just stop here
I have some examples so in this case the
models that Michelle just explained to
you generate who's winning and what
happened for these images and in the
interest of time we thank you but if
anybody has a quick question for either
Michelle or Lucy now okay maybe you can
catch them in the hallway if you do next
up is Jason Williams also from Emma
sorry
okay can everyone hear me all right is
this on okay I see some thumbs up great
so I'm going to talk about the other end
of the spectrum building task oriented
dialogue systems using an end to end
framework called hybrid code networks so
first introduce hybrid code networks
these are an LS TM or some kind of
recurrent neural network that take all
of the observable dialogue history as
input and as output give a distribution
over actions to take in here I'll use
actions as template so I won't be
generating arbitrary text this will
simplify the problem to get started in
building a task oriented system
typically there are no dialogues in the
domain of interest if there is not a
training set to draw on so to bootstrap
this process I'll ask the developer to
provide a handful of examples of the
kinds of dialogues that they want to
imitate and I'll show an example a demo
of this in a minute this can either be a
small corpus or you can train the system
interactively then once the system is up
and running to some reasonable extent
you can deploy it to a friendly set of
users collect some dialogues and then
look at transcripts and make corrections
those augment the training sets training
set grows and once the system is up and
running at a sort of a good enough level
of performance with a high enough volume
you can switch on reinforcement learning
and at the end I'll show some some quick
results for how that can be done this
this approach and I'll the next slide
we'll go into this in more detail is
fully situated in encode so I can
express domain knowledge in the form of
code concretely that means I can give
business rules that constrain which
actions are available this is important
because if you're building for example a
banking system you want to be able to
code relationships like the person must
be logged in before they're allowed to
transfer funds that's not a relationship
you want to learn you want to code for
that and be able to test it that has a
serendipitous side effect that also it
will
reduce the complexity of the learning
problem actions can also refer to API
calls and so API calls here are
first-class citizens or communicative
actions and API actions so let me
quickly show you what a loop of this
looks like and they'll give you a quick
demo so on the left here is a chat
interface and the person types in what's
the weather this week in Seattle so
that's going to get presented to the RNN
in a couple of different ways feature
eyes in a couple of ways there's a bag
of words vector utterance embedding
vector this allowed us to capture both
proprietary terms and also synonymous of
the boxes of pre-trained embedding model
to abstract entities there's a separate
entity extraction model the demo here
I'm going to use Luis which is a
Microsoft cognitive service that process
of entity extraction produces mentions
of text mentions that have a type that
gets passed a code that the developer
provides that lets them resolve the VINs
dimensions entities in their domain that
then outputs context features for
example which entities are now in
context in this dialog so which entities
have I recognized so far and also an
action mask and that's where the
developer can express this domain these
domain constraints over which actions
are available and not the RNN produces
the distribution over the action
templates that the system knows how to
take and then the action mask gets
element wise multiplied with that to for
certain actions to zero so this mask is
your opportunity to clamp certain
actions to zero then choose what action
to take if this is supervised learning
then that means take the max its
reinforcement learning you sample from
this you then do entity substitution so
in this example that city mentioned you
would take the value city and substitute
it back in then depending on the action
type if it's an API call you would
execute that API call that could be an
actuator that presents rich content or
makes the robot produce a particular
gesture it can also be a sensor that
return that returns some API results
it's a feature that can be passed back
to the RNA and then if it's a textual
action you render that to the user and
then this is a stateful model so you
pass back in the action that was just
taken so this is the action this is the
the the operational loop for hybrid code
networks and that's what's driving what
I'm going to show you in just a second
so in this interactive demonstration
this is in the weather domain and I
provided code that connects to the
Weather Underground API to look up
weather forecasts and I've seeded this
with three entities cities dates and
forecasts and three actions which city
which day and play a forecast I've also
added three relationships here so ask
don't ask
so only ask the city and a if you don't
already know it so common sense and
don't play the forecast if you're unable
to so this is common sense but in a this
could be a more complicated relationship
in a say in a banking system or so on
okay so now I'm going to do a demo
actually if I sit down can people even
see me down here okay I'll sit down so I
can type Oh No so it's the perfect wrong
height okay so I'm going to be typing
into Skype over here I haven't figured
out how to make the text and Skype any
bigger so I'm sorry for that so on the
Left I will start by saying what's the
weather in Seattle so that's the user
typing something in now what comes back
is for me the developer as the teacher
and you see it's recognized that Seattle
is a city and now there's a distribution
over the three actions notes how to take
the first one is has all the probability
mass because of the rules that I've
expressed so there's really no machine
learning yet that's interesting as a
teacher I'll say yes I want you to take
action number one so ask for which day
the system will then come back and take
that action and now as the user I'll say
today so that's the users input the
system will come back and say ok I
recognize today as a date and now I'll
play the I want to play the weather
forecast now
so great go ahead and do that this is
now the weather forecast for Seattle for
today and now let's say the user might
say thanks
well now none of these actions are
appropriate actions at this point this
is the end users do this real users will
come along with things you didn't expect
so what I can do is I can type in a new
action this is me saying ok system I
want you to take that action in this
situation and what happens at this point
is this actually gets added to the
catalog of actions the model gets
retrained given the dialogue so far and
the dialogue is now replayed through the
LST M up to this point and that's now
what this model would do at this point
if that were the preceding training
dialogue then I could continue along
instead I'm going to go on to the next
conversation so now this is imagine that
person number two comes up and uses the
system and they might say what's the
weather in San Francisco today so in
this example I'm providing multiple
entities that's ok and now you can see
that action no problem that I added that
doesn't have any constraints associated
with it so now the machine learning
process really is being asked to do
something it wants to play the forecast
great go ahead and do that now maybe the
person might say what's let's say how
about tomorrow
I can recognize tomorrow as a day as a
date and it wants to play the forecast
that's great and I think before I typed
in thanks so I'll say oops I'll say
thank you which is lexically different
but because there's a word embedding
model that's pre trained is a concept of
synonymous oh I have a chance of getting
this right and I do so the system comes
back and says no problem so so far so
good so now this is the sort of the
interactive teaching approach you can
imagine building this up and entering in
more but let me switch over now and I'll
turn that teaching mode off and I'll
start a new conversation and show you
what
it would look like for an end-user that
comes along and rather than show you
things working well I'm going to I'm
going to continue to break it so I'll
say find restaurants so there is no this
system has no capacity to help with this
obviously it says which day I won't
belabor this I'll just go on to the next
conversation maybe someone else comes
along and says search for toy stores and
again there's nothing that can help with
this now this is what happens when you
launch a system you know people come
along with unexpected things and that's
okay that's not broken that's that's a
normal part of system development so
what happens on the right hand side here
is these are the logged conversations
isn't that what the developer can see
for what occurred so if I look at this
conversation oh here the system said
which day that's not right and in fact
none of these are right I want to add a
new action so I'm going to type in sorry
I can't help with that this will do that
same process it will add this action
rebuild the model and then redeploy the
model so it's available and if I look at
this action or this dialogue here sorry
I can't help with that that's right so
I'll go ahead and submit that and then
just to close the loop once that has
deployed I can pick this up in here and
we'll see if I if I get it right so
let's see I had search for choice fine
let's say look for barbershop so
lexically different but semantically
kind of similar sorry I can't help with
that how about what's the weather in
Dallas and which day out today and we
can still play weather forecast so you
can see how you can go back and forth
between doing interactive teaching you
can you can look at blog dialogues so
let me so that's sort of anecdotal in
interactional I'll get so just briefly
gloss some quantitative results I think
I have just maybe two minutes left so
this is a
data set released by Facebook it's
called the baby dialog data set it's
derived from the second dialogue state
tracking challenge data the task 5 the
column on the left is simulated data the
task 6 on the right is human computer
data that's been sort of post processed
so on the left if you if task 5 and
simulated it if you know the rules then
it's possible to so the task here they
give you example dialogues in a training
set you have to try to predict what next
system action the system should take in
a test set so on the Left if you know
the rules then you can get to a hundred
percent
these are past papers that have proposed
various neural network architectures for
end-to-end learning and on the right the
rules that do much less well and the
learned methods - - quite a bit better
the past methods use very little domain
knowledge they're really learning
everything intent this approach I've
described does support the integration
of domain knowledge so I've done that so
there's more intelligence that's fits in
here I've injected some intelligence in
here so if you're willing to do that the
benefit then is that you can completely
recover the behavior of of this
rule-based simulation and then you can
also do better than past work on on
learning in the real human computer
setting which is very noisy just one
last slide just to Glaus some
reinforcement learning results this is a
different setting again this is an named
dialing this black line is if you do
sort of standard reinforcement learning
the citizeness is in simulation and then
the colored lines a nice property of
this model is that reinforcement
learning supervised learning you're
optimizing the same model you're just
changing the loss function and the
colored lines here show if you add
increasing numbers of pre-training
supervised learning dialogues so just
example successful trajectories and this
gives you a a big lift in where you
start and you get to an optimal level of
performance quite a bit faster so just
to briefly conclude this is looking at
that other end of the spectrum how to
build task oriented systems in an
end-to-end using an end-to-end approach
this is
for a particular domain hybrid code
networks combine an Ellis TM with code
you can express the domain knowledge
encode code the things that are easy to
learn the things that it makes sense to
learn you can use this in interactively
by providing a corpus of labeled
examples or with reinforcement learning
and the I think that the quantitative
results look pretty strong and it's
useful for building rail systems real
practical systems so I'll leave it there
thanks or reinforcement learning system
or what is the reward function yeah so
the reward function is you get a plus
one if you successfully transfer the
user to the person they're trying to
call and everything else every intern
you intermediary action gets zero if you
transfer the person to the wrong place
then you get minus one and the user will
this does not get to 100% by
construction the simulated user will
randomly give up at some point they'll
get frustrated if things go on too long
also sometimes they will want to call
someone who's not in the directory by by
construction by design
they'll also not you know answer the
questions they're asked directly all the
time it's a very simple reward function
and it's all delayed there's no shaping
there's nothing to help the system to
find the right path until they've
discovered a successful path okay thanks
Jessica
next up is Jackie Chan from McGill
you
okay great can y'all hear me okay great
so I'll be talking about moving towards
world level understanding for
conversational agents so as you probably
don't need convincing of conversational
agents have many possible uses from say
technical troubleshooting to medical
diagnosis to maybe shopping or marketing
applications or general chitchat so
we've seen a wide range of these types
of systems mentioned in some of the
previous talks so but a corollary of
this is that because they have so many
possible application settings there is
probably very little data for your
particular domain or application of
interest so that's going to be one theme
of my talk and that relates to some of
the goals that I think that about dialog
agents must exhibit so here are two of
them that it's not exhaustive so I think
that Dalek agents must be robust and
useful so they have to be robust in the
sense that you should not need that much
additional training data or additional
engineering if possible for every word
or entity or domain or genre or task
that you want to develop an agent for
and on the other hand you also want your
agent to be useful in the sense that
they should be able to understand and
correctly process various events
entities and relations beliefs
intentions desires and sentiment
emotions and attitudes and so forth so
whether or not you explicitly represent
these in your models so all of these
things in your model that's a lot more
up for debate but the very least they
should be able to handle and process
them so one question to ask is um so
these days are lsdm models are very
standard in NLP and everyone loves them
so one question to ask is if you just
train them in a very standard than all
the way how much do they satisfy these
particular goals and desiderata so as a
case study one of my former undergrads
that Michael knows already and also in
collaboration with Jacques we know from
McGill University we looked at whether
we can predict dialogue success in human
human dialogues so this is work that's
going to appear in sick battle this year
so first we created a data set from
stack overflow comm for put the global
of predicting these
in these conversations so since this is
a technical domain you have questions
like a C so say user a asks a some
technical question about stacktrace
window being closed and how do you read
this lay it and a second user gives an
answer and then gives it a say says
thanks I don't know how overlooked it so
this is an example of a successful
dialogue successful conversation so we
came up with a model based on the LS TM
architecture and in fact we adapted that
model a bit so that it better represents
the turn-based nature of these dialogues
and we trained it in the standard
supervised setup so first of all we get
a nice fairly good performance results
so in terms of recognizing successes
versus failures if you look at the
success cases you get an f1 of say 89 if
you train on the full conversation
thread and 73 on the failure case but we
were also interested in understanding
why these are models are able to achieve
this performance so we ran an ablations
a kind of ablation study where we took
away some of the data and see what the
how much the performance drops so if you
look only at the last comment in the
thread you actually get just a small
drop in performance whereas you trained
on everything except for the last
comment you get a much more substantial
drop in performance especially on the
field failure cases so these are these
results suggest that the lsdm model is
picking up mostly on discourse cues so
for example if a very strong cue is
whether or not the user at the end
expresses gratitude so you can see that
in this previous case just by looking at
seeing that the last comment is thanks I
don't know how to overlook that you can
already tell that it's a success and
that's not really surprising I guess
right so the lsdm model it's trained to
really optimize for what you tell it to
optimize and for this particular task
that's the most useful cue and that's
what it makes the most useful what's
much harder is to be able to develop
this understanding of whether the
original information need was really
satisfied by looking at the semantics of
the question and the semantics of the
answer and seeing whether they match in
some way
so that's what arguably we need to do if
we want to have these individual
components be more widely useful and
reusable so the angle that my team has
been deeply attacking this problem from
is to look at incorporating more world
knowledge into these conversational
agents and other NLP applications so
ideally we'd like to incorporate
additional information such as a
wikipedia pages or wordnet or a
knowledge base in the structure of
knowledge races or specialized
dictionaries or if you're working in a
specialized domain maybe you're you are
running some website focusing our TV
show so you have TV show descriptions or
you're selling some products with it
with your site hustle startup company
and you have product descriptions so we
would like to be able to leverage these
in order to better train our models and
potentially to generalize better and
develop more robust systems as well
towards these new entities and events
and tasks so now I'd like to talk a
little bit about some newer work that
has been done by I recently graduated
master's student at Tong long also in
collaboration with Amano Benjy Orion lo
and Dinah pickup that's going to appear
at am NLP so we thought about the
problem of trying to model rare entities
where named entities in text so what we
did was first of all we decided to
collect a data set or actually we
offloaded this work to previous work so
there's already this wiki links corpus
developed by saying at L on 2012 which
was originally used for current
resolution so the property of this
corpus which makes it interesting is
that it's a web corpus where there are
spans annotated with links to Wikipedia
pages so what we did was we enhance that
data set by also extracting definitions
from that Wikipedia article and in
particular we extracted the first
sentence as a definition for that
particular entity we wanted to see how
we can look at the interplay between our
definition of an entity and how it's
used in context in this corpus
so similar to some of the machine
comprehension work that if you were here
this morning you might you saw we also
defined a possibility close task for to
to test our models so basically the idea
is that we like to we have our context
so here's the example from before and
we're going to remove the entity from
where it originally occurred and replace
it by a blank and we like to see if we
can figure out which was the original
entity that actually sit there given
access to the definitions of all of the
candidate entities and just with a
little bit more detail so the set of
kind of entities was the set of entities
that originally occurred in the same
document but this is something that you
can play around with if you want to
easier task or harder task so here in
this example to fill in the blank you
have William Blake which was the correct
answer but you might also have say peter
ackroyd
emanuel swedenborg along with their
particular candidate entity definitions
so we proposed the model to try to do a
better job of this prediction task and
we proposed this double encoder model
which is a series of two neuronal
networks o2l SCM networks one which
encodes the context and one which
encodes the definition and then it also
combines the information from the two so
on the contact side you have an LCM
which reads the context word by word
including the blank and on the
definition side you have another LST M
which reads the definition word by word
and then once you have the encoding you
pass it into the context in the
appropriate slot and at the end you also
combine the information from both
encoded representations to may predict a
possibility score for whether that
entity fits into that blank and actually
we worked a little bit more to develop a
hierarchical version of this model that
better exploits the long-range
dependencies between choices within the
same document but for reasons of time I
won't go into that here so here are the
some brief subset of the results from
that paper so here's the random
performance you get around 30% correct
just by randomly choosing entity and
with a standard LST M language model you
can get a small
boost up to 40 but you really get much
larger games if you incorporate the
information from the definitions from
the from the entity kind of definitions
so that was a very nice for us and to
dig a little bit deeper into these
results we also broke down the results
by the entity frequency so on the x axis
x axis here we have the entities entity
types separated by their frequencies in
the corpus from below five to more than
20 and here we have the blue bars which
are the performances for the content
encoder the standard LS TM and the red
and orange bars represents the
performance of our models which
incorporates the definitions so what you
see is that the gap is between the blue
bars and the other bars is much larger
for the rare entities compared to the
more frequent entities where there's a
gap but it's a there's still a gap
that's much smaller so that was nice so
it really shows that just that one short
sentence which is a definition can help
you a lot with your modeling and
furthermore we looked a bit of some of
the cases so we found on this
interesting case from the data set so
you have we heard from Audrey bounzer
who is with the Free Gaza movement she
was in blank Cyprus so the standard
language model predicted Istanbul which
is perhaps plausible because Istanbul is
a large well-known city in the Middle
East but it's not in Cyprus right
whereas if you had access to the
definitions and you knew that you knew
the fact and then you can correctly
predict among the candidate set and
figure out that it's long exact and not
just that but it turns out that Larnaca
is this entity it only appeared twice in
the entire corpus and it did not appear
in the training set at all so this was
only appeared in the test set but this
model was still able to get it correct
so that was a nice finding for us
yeah so those are those are a summary as
a result from that paper so it seems
like if you want to be able to
generalize your system and have more
robust systems for new types of tasks
are new types of data maybe one
additional source of resources that you
can exploit is these external resources
so I think that in the future it'd be
nice to move beyond end-to-end training
for a single task because for most tasks
you just don't have enough training data
for these neural networks to work well
on and also I think that it'd be nice to
move more towards more modularized than
reusable components so this is these are
some of the directions into where it's
having these on modular eyes and useable
components that my team is working on so
I talked a little bit about using
external information for entities and
events and also one of my students is
working on common sense reasoning and so
we'd like to be able to incorporate a
Content net or other external sources of
knowledge for that and we've also done
some work on reusable components for
language generation which might tie back
into dialogue so for example one of my
students looked at making predictions
about sentence aggregation decisions for
natural language generation alright so
thank you very much I'd like to thank my
great group of students and
collaborators at the reasoning Learning
Lab at McGill University and also my
funding sources Thanks
[Applause]
Thank You Jackie I guess it's
interesting to me that you are able to
use the single definition that you're
getting out of the Wikipedia I guess as
a I would have expected that that might
have come from the neural models if it
had processed sufficient amounts of text
that kind of it would have had the
background knowledge that was necessary
for a Larnaca so if for example if
Wikipedia had been already part of the
data that you had used to compute the
vectors before would that have fallen
out or do you need specifically to know
that that is a definition yeah that's a
great question so I think it probably
helps if you really specifically know
that that's the definition because the
way people write definitions and the
kinds of information that's expressed in
a definition are different than when you
already assume you know about that know
something about the entity and you talk
about it assuming that as background
knowledge so I think what would be
really interesting is that we can
automatically predict in your training
set which types of sentences containing
entities are more definition like in
which are more like you assume you know
something about the entity and you're
just talking about the entity and if you
know that then maybe you can just throw
it all in and then just train on that
but before we have that I think having
that separation seems to really help the
model but yeah maybe we should run an
experiment where we throw all the
definitions in and just try and last up
is Ian Lane from CMU
okay so can anyone hear me okay okay we
are now so I thought I'd finish off the
session today not talking about neural
networks however haha that's what we're
doing at the moment so this is another
neural network talk but really focused
on looking at human human conversation
and looking at how we can train systems
based on based on data that already
exists so sort of the goal of my work is
can we learn to perform tasks going to
the dialogue by modeling human
conversations so we've got a user
calling in to a system I'm looking
forward to telling restaurant for dinner
there's an agent on the other end who's
listening to them on the line has access
to databases and all the information
they need and they can respond in
real-time whether this is our messaging
or whether this is our a call center and
you have a dialogue flowing through if
you look at call centers today typically
you when you make a call it's very task
orientated you're caught in a certain
number to solve a certain problem and
there's a shocking amount of data out
there so one company we are interacting
with they have over 10 million
conversations every year millions of
customers and now close to a hundred
million dialogues in their data over
many years of business so can we
leverage this data to build more
human-like or more intuitive dialogue
systems in the real world
so the first I'll talk about is looking
at agent models and what we want to do
here is look at data that already exists
and be able to train an agent that can
interact with the user understand what
they're saying do the appropriate lookup
or knowledge search as required and then
respond to the user with the goal of
getting the task solved um so sort of a
starting point of this is similar to
what other others have talked about with
new conversational models and so using
your networks lsdm networks and then
encoder/decoder networks to take a input
a set of previous sentences and generate
an output as a set of words and in some
cases it can work very reasonable
example from the the group at Google and
their neuro conversational model from a
couple of years ago hello hello how are
you today I'm good what's your name I'm
Julia when were you born July 20th
what year were you born 1977 where are
you from and you can simulate dialogues
in this type of manner that seem
reasonable and flow quite nicely however
sometimes they completely fail again
because you and the way they don't so
here the machine starts off the dialogue
hi the human response hi the machine
said could you please let me know what
is the operating system you're using the
human said Linux okay this is the issue
with the system performance Nezzer tools
and that's something that a human will
not generate and even a well-structured
dialogue system should not generate so
the systems are as good as the model
structure in the data you give it but
there's inherent constraints in using a
purely neuro conversational model to
solve tasks in the real world so what we
look at here is trainable task
orientated models for dialogue assuming
we have lot of data from agents that
include what the agent said and what
actions they took and what we're trying
to build is first an agent model where
we try to understand the users input in
context or in this case in dialogue
context taking appropriate action given
the user input and the dialogue dialogue
and task history and these actions can
include responding to the user
performing an API call a database lookup
or performing some other type of action
or combination of actions within that
turn and then updating the dialogue
state for the next turn we can leave a
model the user as well and we are trying
to estimate what their goal is or if
they have a goal change so we've built a
agent model where we we've simplified
the problem a little bit so rather than
using a word based input we deal X lies
the input and this allows our training
data to cover much much wider variety of
input as a concern we use a dialogue
state model which I'll show Nix
by an LSTA model that if the mates the
dialogue state after every turn either
by the user or the agent which I to
estimate belief states that are required
for API lookup and then we can perform
one of many are mini actions so we can
issue an idea API call and process the
result so it's not just the call that
you make so you make a call you get the
results from it and how should you pick
which results to provide back to the
user that's part of them the model
actions that we need to estimate a model
we need to update our results of
required and create an appropriate
response and in a response again rather
than generating word by word
we take templates and there could be
many thousands or millions of templates
of responses that a user or an agent has
had before and use the closest matching
template to respond to the user so this
is a overview of the new network model
that we use in for the agent the side of
our system where we have a dialogue
history and dialogue States estimated
with an LSTA model we take a user each
user input and estimator the in bidding
a semantics in bidding of that using a
recurrent neural network we are then
using our hidden dialogue state to
estimate but all of the belief states as
well as estimate what the appropriate
responses and what type of API query and
entity pointer to use or what what
responsible in the knowledge base to
respond back to the user and so here in
this case the user has asked somewhere
within a dialogue is there another
restaurant that serves and kellian food
from our model we update an estimate
okay they're just looking for Italian
but they're looking for an alternative
Italian last time it was our top based
query we should respond with the second
and so a lot of the new network paths
that you or new level models today if
you don't put in these it and here at
constraints about the API query and
taking the response from the API query
and responded to the user
appropriately here us using this
knowledge based indicator and into the
pointers then you can get into crazy
loops which aren't reasonable where the
same response comes again and again or
jumps jumps around randomly so modeling
of action tasks in addition to the
dialogue that's critical to get these
systems working so the way of trending
these models are really we looking at
two approaches supervised training and
reinforcement learning we take a large
amount of data that we've all defied
natural language understanding and deal
excellensation to we train on all of the
dialogues in the human to human
interaction and at the moment assuming
we have turn-based back and forward we
use this to train our neural network
models we look at as I mentioned two
approaches supervised training where we
can really treat this as a
classification task pattern given the
dialogue history the API calls that have
been made and the responses generated by
those API calls what is the appropriate
template and information to respond to
the user and the second is looking at
reinforcement learning where we optimize
based on the end of dialogue reward how
well did the dialogue go did we get the
responsive user wanted and how many
Tunes were required to get that as an
alternative way to train these models so
we've been trying on some part of the
available datasets this is the same beby
data set that Jason had been had been
working with and we're able to get said
to the outperformance on this type of
training data but there are some very
apparent issues and so because we're
training these models for dialogue we're
limited but we're limited on training on
static data between users there there
are a couple of issues that we have to
have to overcome so one of it is often
our system will put out something that's
very reasonable but just because it
doesn't match the training data that's
getting penalized and we want to be able
to improve on that
and additionally they fix the training
data is fixed so the user in our
training data doesn't respond based on
the model of the output just based on
the supervised training data that we
provided and so we want to improve of
that and we look at one method of doing
this by looking at modeling both the
user and the agent to improve the
performance of our agent models before
we deploy them so the goal here is if
I've got a user interacting with the
system and we've got lots of user data
already there we should be able to
simulate new users that have different
goals but interact in a similar manner
and then on the agent side we can trade
a model in a similar way that we did
before and we can actually train these
models jointly together to improve the
performance overall so here we introduce
a user model that takes us an input I
use a goal and from that goal it's using
examples from real human human
interaction to interact with our agent
model and by going back and forward they
are constrained by the training data so
that the output that they're generators
is very fast specific and mimics human
dialogue but they can optimize the
parameters internally to give us the
best throughput or the best performance
so we here we introduce a second model
I'll use the model again using something
very similar structure to a an agent
model within a dialogue system but
they're using it to take in a user goal
taking dialogue history both from the
user and from the agent and generate an
output as the user would that think it
gets passed to the agent model and by
iteratively go through dialogues both of
these systems can be optimized either
independently or jointly to improve the
overall performance of the system and so
here we take our user output and this
goes into the user input of the agent
model and then in the next dialogue turn
the output of the agent model gives
taken as the input to the the user model
so we end up training a model jointly
between the two
of these where we have the appropriate
encoders for both the knowledge base
input as well as the user goal and we
can simulate the dialogues between our
simulated our simulated user which has
trained on again human human to human
data and our dialogue agent which is
interacting with us and trying to solve
the task orientated task so we've got
these up and running with a different of
different different types of
reinforcement learning and what we found
is the with joint training of both of
these models we can much quicker and
much more successfully I resolve
dialogues over time so after we run
something close to 20,000 dialogues
between the simulated agent the
simulated user and a neural network
agent we get a success rate of around 65
percent which is much higher than a
baseline distrained with trained with
supervised training and more effective
than just updating and using
reinforcement Lane learning on the agent
by itself and so we think this is a
interesting area to explore more we're
still to do the human evaluations on
these to validate that the output system
is actually better when interacting in
the real world in then our baseline
systems so this is an example of the
output that we get and here with our
simulated agent and simulated user and
as I've mentioned a lot of the dialogues
or most of the dialogues that we've seen
through from the simulation approach are
very reasonable and the success rate per
dialogue or the overall success rate is
about 65% so there still are quite a
number of challenges to to overcome to
make this work in the real world one of
it is data and so getting logs of
dialogue along with API calls and
responses is required for the approaches
we're using at the moment but we found
this type of approach works very well
for a lot of
kotas dialogues especially those that
contain a combination of social and task
under the dialog within a and within a
single task and also include external
knowledge base lookup in action so
dealing with products or service abort
and call centers and messaging
interfaces seems to be a good task for
this type of type of approach and we can
model both the agent and the user and
conversation at the moment we're just
we're thrown away this information but
it's possible to bring us in those
personas so with the name within an
agent rather than modeling modeling all
agents in general you can model a
specific agent within your call center
or your messaging center and even with
users with sufficient data from a
specific user you can start estimated
personas and estimating how they will
interact in dialogue by modeling them
through a a new network as well the
final thing that we're starting to look
into using this approach as
bootstrapping new systems on-the-fly
so in the current system we train on
large amounts of data we simulate more
dialogue and generate models based on
that but it's possible to do this online
on the fly by getting real dialog as it
comes in in a in a call center or
messaging center scene if the agent is
responding or using the suggestions that
are provided and when they are we learn
from it and when they not we can feed
that back into the system immediately
and get the system to bootstrap within
hundreds of dialogues rather than tens
of millions of dialogues and so that's a
an area that we are exploring thank you
[Applause]
still have a few minutes my kids could
use the microscope
this is a very pragmatic question I've
been looking at call center dialogues
and and found to my surprise that many
agents simply cut and paste from
information that they're given and so I
was looking at quite a large corpus last
week and a good percentage of it didn't
actually make any sense and so I was
wondering whether you've had better luck
training on those data yeah so we and
weapon call centers as well the ones
that we've been looking at if you look
at the top 10% of agents compared for
the longer tail of the 90 percent
there's a there's a dramatic change in
quality and so even look at him the
human dialogue I see I've seen lots of
dialogue failures but this there are
especially the the good agents are
really really good at dialogue and sort
of the goal here is can we take the
quality of those top 10% of dialogue of
agents for the Nicol center replicate
them well enough so you get better
experience even for the longer tail of
the line the nigel so too soon so in the
in the training data we not thrown away
quite a lot because the dialogue isn't
of high enough quality and we don't use
that within model training so one we
have metrics about specific agents and
use that and others we were just looking
at length of call and the quality just
that the last two or three utterances
was the customer happy or not
other questions
actually I have a follow-up on macro so
I haven't really looked at call center
data so I don't know what it looks like
but my impression is that sometimes
these call center workers are reading
from a script' yep and going down a flow
diagram and to what extent of the models
if that's the case that's being used to
generate this data to workcenter the
models we you know learning a script
that a human Road so in especially for
product product support there's a lot of
structured information structured data
flow that is given and the dialogue
system start learning that what we found
though is they're still even given a
dialogue flow this is what you should be
doing there's an agent in the call
center for this product there are those
agents who can perform it better than
others and what we do end up learning is
something very similar to the data flow
that is provided there but the goal is
the quality should be better than sort
of a state based or manually designed
state based dialogue system all right
well thank you very much and thanks to
all of you I mean I think we saw a lot
of work with this ferment that's going
on in the field of dialogue right now
and I think what's interesting is that
not that much of it is crept into actual
experiences that consumers or people at
work are encountering yet but it's
coming fast it's just shocking to me how
rapidly this field is moving at it
really feels like translation you know
10 15 years ago or maybe speech in the
same era where I think in five ten years
some of these experiences are going to
work really well in a way that will be
shocking and after many many years
decades of effectively stasis things are
really exploding in this area and I
think we're going to see the benefits of
it in the real world pretty soon so
thank you everybody
oh gee Kristin oh hey
sorry I have to take issue with that
last week on a sedan and I think I said
yeah in the introduction too so it's not
like dialogue because nothing's been
happening for 50 years there's sig dial
there's all of these systems including
Cortana and Siri you know there's been a
lot of activity and and consciousness
with the public with interacting with a
lot of systems and dialogue and call
centers and all kinds of systems without
the neural network stuff and I think you
know this technology does seem very
promising but I haven't seen anything
today or recently that leads me to
believe that there'll be the quantum
leap that we saw in speech and
translation because we're not at the
state-of-the-art yet with this
technology let alone surpassing it so so
I mean I think it's definitely worth
pursuing and interesting to look at it
but I don't see we should throw away the
last 50 years of the other work and and
I don't see a reason at this stage to
believe that we're going to surpass that
anytime soon right Point ticket I mean
we saw a few minutes if anybody who
spoke or anybody else wants to do a mini
panel discussion here does anybody want
to respond to that no I think it's an
interesting question I think that's an
interesting topic to discuss all right
well thank you very much everybody
thanks see you
[Applause]